the tale of the Princess Kaguya is the
newest anime film from Studio Ghibli in
my opinion one of the greatest if not
the greatest animation studio in
existence please keep making movies and
it's directed by ESL Takahata who
brought us grave of the fireflies one of
the best anime films ever made and a
very touching war story this film is
based on a story in Japanese folklore
called the tale of the Bamboo Cutter
about a little girl who grows out of the
bamboo is raised by a family eventually
turned into a princess and eventually
her odd and strange supernatural
beginnings come back to haunt her I was
so excited to see this movie not just
because I love anime but because Studio
Ghibli has made some of the best
animated entertainments ever
I mean Hayao Miyazaki's movies alone are
some of the best movies ever made not
just animated movies have you ever seen
my neighbor totoro or spirited away or
Princess Mononoke or Kiki's Delivery
Service a castle in the sky or Ponyo or
any of his movies this year's the wind
rises the man's a genius and Studio
Ghibli continues their reign of
Awesomeness with this movie I love this
film it is such a unique and original
looking anime I have never seen a movie
with such bold and rich colorful artwork
that just leap off of the screen without
any computerized elements getting
involved with it you can just tell that
artists created this movie like with
their hands from scratch now I got to
see the subtitled version of this film
at a local independent theater that's
very new called the night light and they
actually gave me the privilege of
introducing this film to the audience
which was mind-blowing and really a
dream come true for me and through that
I'm creating a really great relationship
with that theater to help raise
awareness for it but also to bring you
guys more cool entertainment in the
future interviews and things like that
so definitely look forward to that
Studio Ghibli's movies are largely
viewed as kids films you know certain
ones like Princess Mononoke and others
like that aren't really kids films but
for the most part they're viewed as
family entertainment movies but they're
not like America's family entertainment
trust me because this film especially
has a very mature and realistic look and
life as this girl grows up in the
wilderness you see her enjoy life she
loves it she loves to fry
around in the woods and when she's
forced to take on this princess role by
her will meeting but not entirely
helpful father life becomes very hard
for her as various suitors come and try
to woo her and you get to see a girl who
really doesn't understand her place in
the world which is a theme that is well
explored in movies you know characters
who are out of place or feel out of the
ordinary which most people do on the
earth to be honest and that's one of the
things I loved about this film it took
that so seriously it showed such a
mature and realistic and non-glossy
portrayal of what life can be like
sometimes for adolescents there isn't a
part of this movie that feels fictional
despite some of the supernatural
elements that are happening which by the
way there are moments of extreme beauty
in this movie that had my mouth drop
particularly a sequence where she bursts
out of her house and anger and runs into
the woods it's some of the most
impressive animation that these eyes
have ever witnessed Princess Kaguya is a
movie of raw emotion extreme childlike
wonder and glee amazing animation and
it's one of Studio Ghibli's best I'm
gonna give this movie and a I think it's
a beautiful beautiful animated movie if
you guys get a chance to see it or if
it's playing near you definitely go
check it out because Studio Ghibli and
the movies that they are making
absolutely need to be supported
speaking of independent films and
independent filmmakers shutterstock.com
has graciously offered to sponsor my
videos and because of that you guys are
getting a special offer it's an amazing
website that has tons of stock footage
and stock clips and stock images that
you can use in your movie things like
shots of New York or shots of la
helicopter shots things that people in
our position just can't get yet even
though we really want to make our movies
epic with the coupon code Chris 1014 you
can get 20% off whatever you feel you'd
like to have from that site which is
totally awesome so thank you so much
guys definitely check out
shutterstock.com coupon code 1014 thank
you as always for watching I really
appreciate it and definitely check out
princess kaguya if you get a chance to
if it's playing near you seek it out I
really want some of these movies to make
some money you know it's not always like
transformers and everything just topping
them
box office let's have some of these
better more independent and richly
powerful movies make some money thanks
as always for watching guys I'll be back
very soon with the review for Super
Smash Brothers for the Wii U and a
recorded match with a pretty awesome
youtuber included in the review and I
hope you enjoy that thanks as always and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stockman eyes